thousand years was captured him the
secret history of tongues for us
[Music]
y'all want to see their robot that's
supposed to be here
we're jeans man we get away we say
anything I was just normal kids for my
world fell apart look at me
wake up canopies a to normal school does
in normal life
some kids tease me Wow Lizzy far as
you're concerned my boyfriend how long's
that video uh
they say you run like a girl family now
you're going to carry on promise don't
expect Denny's bedtime stories you throw
like a girl
five like a crow
[Music]
you out of your mind you're not going
anywhere with me I'll stay and I want to
fight them think you're badass huh it's
okay to be a kid little JLo funny which
you can do when all you have less
depends on it done fight like a girl
yeah I felt like a girl coming with me
or what
don't you
[Music]
we call vision
turn around what are you getting your
mouth lots of clothes right now come on
then
careful
you get back here home think about what
you did
you
you